you know what you you know it's so funny
that you're here because um I wanna be
real for a second Oh God
why cuz I know you're just gonna do
something no to where we're not gonna
talk for five years
we're gonna be in our 70s I was it's so
weird that you and I would meet at that
time and that we would still be here
yeah this it's pretty cool it's pretty
cool bro you I'm telling you man you you
are a sense of motivation for me like
like you've I've had like you know like
when you have those paths that cross and
then we're still on the same track
trying to chase the same dream and then
we pat we cross again
and I I don't know how many times you
cry yeah but that one went to you at The
Comedy Store and you and you had me uh
you know go up in front of Mitzi yeah
you did that for me i yeah yeah or how
about that time when I was working at uh
North Iraq and I was doing like catering
for a hot company oh yeah then I was
trying to write for you oh that's it
that's right that's right yeah and then
and then you were feeding me all this
food and [ __ ] yeah I just thought you
were the richest guy in the world you
know MADtv yeah yeah but you know what
something that is that how about I'm
just gonna keep talking know what my
point about when you're in now in Vegas
and uh this the second time we came and
then even the first time you've put me
up in your I still up in your house yeah
I slept in my house but the second time
you you told me to move to LA yeah and
you're like what are you doing here yeah
yeah yeah and that's that we barely even
knew each other I think that was only
two years into our relationship and then
you were right away you're like what are
you doing here yeah like you need to be
in LA are you doing a Sean Connery thing
on your face or hold on let's do the
inspirational [ __ ] and then go to the
joke let the people sitting in the
cubicle that enjoy tire belly which is
very enjoy it yeah you know we let them
get motivated as well okay yeah cuz they
have a goddamn tiger belly sticker of
your girlfriend a little tiny pink dick
on her back have a little dick that's
fine I have that too I have a little
dick yeah
but anyways I want you to know that that
you are very inspirational throughout my
whole career yeah but anyway and you
should hear that because I don't think
you hear that enough but the thing is is
the truth is this and you've always told
me how can I follow Ju the truth bro let
me tell you Apple you said no I need to
say it because I've been holding it in
for a long time when you told me to move
to LA and I said no and I remember when
you left you're like ah you did that
same thing you did when CA where you
just [ __ ] stormed out and you're mad
and then uh and then you got [ __ ]
premium blend and you got [ __ ] mad I
think you got MADtv first and then
premium blend for them and then you got
MADtv that's what it was and I was just
got a couple of damn it but my point is
is this okay this is bad I told myself I
should we tell it cuz those would have
been my gigs no but this is that you've
always been you could always see it you
know I mean like when I fought for a saw
I used to say this a lot but I see first
saw Dahlia or people like that they're
intrinsically funny who are just you
know charismatic and are just funny
people on stage you have joke writers
right you have guys that could write a
joke and that's valid and that's great
and there's a lot of great joke writers
and joke tellers but then you have
people that are just very funny Eddie
Murphy but him he's like that he's
always been like that to what you've
always been legitimately just a gifted
funny guy and he always a nice kick guy
you know and so I mean that's I mean I
don't really remember a lot of these
times but I've always liked you and I've
always you know we try to help each
other you know and so I'm just saying
that trying to be nice and say that I'm
just glad that you're in my life and
even though we don't see each other for
a couple years and whatnot I know that
there's love there
[Music]